bonjour à tous aujourd'hui je voudrais
vous parler d'une découverte
extraordinaire qu'on appelle les
cellules souches induites par
reprogrammation
alors oui je sais dit comme ça ça pas
forcément l'air très sexy mais vous
allez voir que c'est quelque chose qui
va peut-être un jour révolutionné la
médecine
avant de vous parler des cellules
souches induites par reprogrammation il
faut d'abord que je vous explique ce que
c'est qu'une cellule souche je pense que
vous le savez notre corps effet le
cellules comme pour les organismes
vivants d'ailleurs et chez l'être humain
il y en a même un sacré paquet puisque
on peut en compter jusqu'à dix mille
milliards et toutes ses cellules
elles peuvent avoir des formes et des
fonctionnements très différent suivant
leur rôle
par exemple il n'y a pas grand chose de
commun en apparence entre un neurone de
votre cerveau un globule rouge de votre
sang et des cellules de fibres
musculaires et pourtant aussi
différentes qu'elles soient toutes ses
cellules décembre d'une seule et même
cellule de départ c'est la cellule oeuf
celles qui résultent de la fécondation
d'un ovule par un spermatozoïde et qui
s'est ensuite x division cellulaire
jusqu'à donner un organisme complet si
les cellules d'un organisme peuvent être
aussi différentes les unes des autres
alors qu'elles proviennent toutes de la
même cellule à l'origine c'est qu'il
existe un mécanisme qui permet aux
cellules de se spécialiser
certaines vont se spécialiser en
neurones d'autres en globules rouges etc
et ce mécanisme on l'appelle la
différenciation cellulaire alors qu'est
ce que ces cellules souches là dedans
mais c'est justement une cellule qui
n'est pas spécialisée et qui a la
possibilité de se multiplier et de
donner des cellules différenciées
alors c'est pas très compliqué
d'imaginer l'intérêt médical des
cellules souches ainsi on dispose de
cellules qui sont capables de se
différencier en n'importe quelle cellule
spécialisée
on peut imaginer pouvoir les utiliser
pour restaurer des cellules défectueuses
réparer des tissus ou alors carrément
pourquoi pas à reconstruire en entier
des organes c'est ce qu'on appelle la
thérapie cellulaire et on pense
évidemment à des maladies comme la
leucémie le diabète ou bien les
atteintes neurologiques comme la maladie
de parkinson ou la maladie d alzheimer
le problème c'est que des cellules
souches malheureusement on n'en trouve
pas facilement et même des cellules
souches qui soient capables de se
différencier en n'importe quel autre
type de cellule on en trouve
essentiellement qu'à un seul endroit
c'est dans les embryons quand ils sont
un stade d'environ 5 à 6 jours de
développement
c'est ce qu'on appelle les cellules
souches embryonnaires le souci c'est que
je vous cache pas que si vous vous
amusez à prendre un embryon de cinq
jours et à lui piquer des cellules et
ben vous détruisez et donc même pour des
applications médicales détruire des
embryons ça pose quand même de sérieux
problèmes d'éthique et heureusement
c'est là qu'arrive le génie de
l'histoire un chercheur japonais qui
s'appelle shinya yamanaka
pour comprendre l'idée de yamanaka il
faut revenir sur quelque chose que je
vous ai je vous ai dit en apparence il
ya pas grand chose de commun entre
mettons un de vos neurones et un de vos
globules rouges
en fait c'est pas vrai il ya au moins
une chose que ces cellules ont en commun
c'est leur adn
parce qu'en fait quand il ya une
division cellulaire
même si ça débouche sur une
différenciation la dl lui il est
toujours parfaitement recopié à
l'identique
donc toutes les cellules de votre corps
ont exactement le même adn qui est le
même que celui de votre première cellule
or il faut savoir que l'adn c'est en
quelque sorte le plan de montage ou le
manuel de fonctionnement de vos cellules
la plupart des fonctions cellulaires
sont assurés par des protéines et les
protéines elles sont fabriqués grâce aux
plans contenues dans l'adn donc à ce
stade on peut se demander comment est-ce
qu'un neurone et un globule rouge
peuvent êtres si différents et
fonctionner d'une manière si différente
si ils possèdent exactement le même adn
en fait c'est très simple chaque cellule
n'utilise que la partie de l'adn qui lui
est nécessaire pour fonctionner ça veut
dire que un neurone il va uniquement
lire et utiliser la partie de l'adn qui
lui permet de fonctionner comme un
neurone et un globule rouge va
uniquement utiliser la partie de l'adn
qui lui permet d'être un globule rouge
on veut prendre une analogie musical
c'est comme si dans un orchestre
symphonique
chaque musicien disposait de l'ensemble
de la partition de tous les autres
instruments mais ne choisisse de lire et
de jouer que la partie qui lui
correspond et c'est là qu'intervient
l'idée dingue de yamanaka yamanaka s'est
dit puisque toutes les cellules
possèdent exactement le même adn
on doit être capable au moins en théorie
de prendre une cellule différenciée et
de la refaire se comporter comme une
cellule souche
pour ça il suffit de la convaincre
d'aller lire et utiliser les bonnes
parties de l'adn qui lui permettent de
fonctionner comme une cellule souche
alors l'idée peut paraître séduisante
sur le papier mais faut savoir que dans
une quinzaine d'années tout le monde l'a
trouvée complètement impossible et
yamanaka après quand même de sérieux
risques avec sa carrière de chercheur en
voulant poursuivre cette idée alors
qu'est-ce qu'il a fait concrètement et
ben il a pris des cellules différenciées
et puis a commencé à leur injecter tout
un tas de gênes pour voir s'ils étaient
capables de les transformer en cellules
souches et puis un jour à force d'essais
bingo il a fini par trouver un ensemble
de quatre gènes qui quand on les injecte
à une seule différencier la transforment
en cellules souches et donc c'est ce
processus qu'on appelle la
reprogrammation et l'essai
sous ce qu'on obtient en faisant ça on
les appelle les cellules souches
induites donc par opposition aux
cellules souches embryonnaires
cette première expérience elle a été
publié en 2006 par yamanaka et c'était
sur des cellules de souris et un peu
moins d'un an plus tard il a réédité
l'exploit mais cette fois avec des
cellules humaines
donc il a montré qu'on pouvait prendre
des cellules de la peau et les
reprogrammer pour en faire des cellules
souches
alors évidemment ça a fait l'effet d'une
petite bombe parce que du coup ça
ouvrait la possibilité de pouvoir faire
des cellules souches autrement qu'en
utilisant des embryons
à partir de là il ya tout un tas des
types de recherches qui se sont mis à
utiliser cette technique de
reprogrammation et à voir quelles
pouvaient être les applications
thérapeutiques
alors il ya notamment des chercheurs qui
ont montré que l'on pouvait grâce aux
cellules souches induites par
reprogrammation traités chez la souris
des maladies comme la drépanocytose ou
alors un équivalent de la maladie de
parkinson
alors comme toujours les applications
thérapeutiques à l'homme prenne un peu
plus de temps et il ya notamment un
problème à résoudre c'est que ces
cellules souches induites
elles ont une tendance à être instable
et a dégénéré en cellules cancéreuses
évidemment ça pose des problèmes pour
soigner des gens avec donc il ya encore
pas mal de progrès à faire sur la
technique de reprogrammation
mais quand même entre-temps yamanaka a
reçu le prix nobel de médecine c'était
en 2012 donc seulement quelques années
après sa découverte
ce qui est quand même pas si fréquent et
il faut savoir qu'en septembre 2014 a eu
le premier essai thérapeutique chez
l'homme utilisant des cellules souches
induites
donc ça s'est passé au japon et donc
c'est une femme qui souffre d'une
maladie de la rétine qu'on appelle la dm
est là et à qui on a greffé de nouvelles
cellules de rétine et ses cellules
elles sont issues de cellules souches
induites qu'on a obtenus en
reprogrammant des cellules de la peau de
son bras alors il faut voir ce que ça va
donner sur le long terme mais quand même
soigné la rétine à partir de la peau du
bras
moi je trouve ça classe merci d'avoir
suivi cette vidéo si elle vous a plu
n'hésitez pas à la partager m'aider à
faire connaître la chaîne
aussi bien sûr vous abonner vous êtes
déjà coût de 5000 abonnés donc merci à
tence et puis vous pouvez me retrouver
sur facebook sur twitter et j'ai un blog
qui s'appelle aussi science étonnante
merci et à bientôt